Para ser honesto, en la salud con frecuencia
tratamos los síntomas sin tomar en cuenta
las condiciones que te enfermaron desde un principio.
Y hay muchas razones, pero las 3 más importantes
son, primero, no pagamos para eso.
En la salud con frecuencia pagamos por volumen y no por valor.
Le pagamos a los doctores y a los hospitales
por el número de servicios que prestan,
pero no necesariamente por lo saludable que te hacen.
Esto lleva al segundo fenómeno que llamo
el enfoque de "no preguntes, no digas"
sobre las causas de los problemas de salud.
No preguntamos dónde vives o trabajas
porque si hay un problema allí, no sabemos qué decirte.
No es que los médicos no sepan que esto es importante.
En una encuesta reciente a médicos en EE. UU.,
a más de 1000 médicos,
el 80 % dijo que sabían
que las causas de los problemas de sus pacientes
son tan importantes como sus enfermedades
o problemas médicos.
Pero a pesar de este conocimiento generalizado
de la importancia de estas causas,
solo 1 de cada 5 médicos dijeron
que se sentían con la confianza de poder afrontar esos problemas,
de mejorar la salud donde comienza.
Hay un gran bache entre saber que es importante
conocer dónde vive y trabaja el paciente,
y la capacidad de poder hacer algo en el sistema en el que trabajan.
Es un gran problema ahora
porque nos lleva a la pregunta siguiente:
¿De quién es la responsabilidad?
Esto me trae al tercer punto.
La tercera respuesta a la importante pregunta de Verónica.
Parte de la razón de este acertijo
es porque no tenemos suficientes gente "aguas arriba"
en el sistema de salud.
No hay suficientes de ese tercer amigo,
esa persona que va a investigar
quién o qué está lanzando esos niños al agua.
Hoy en día hay muchos en esta categoría
y he tenido el privilegio de conocerlos
en Los Ángeles y en otras partes del país
y alrededor del mundo.
Es importante resaltar que a veces son médicos,
pero no tienen que serlo.
Pueden ser enfermeras, personal clínico,
administradores de la salud, trabajadores sociales.
El título de los que "nadan aguas arribas" no es tan importante.
Lo que es más importante es que todos parecen
compartir la misma habilidad de implementar un proceso
de transformar su asistencia,
transformar la forma de practicar medicina.
El proceso es muy simple.
Es 1, 2 y 3.
Primero, se sientan y dicen,
vamos a identificar el problema clínico entre un grupo particular de pacientes.
Digamos, por ejemplo,
vamos a ayudar a los niños
que entran y salen de hospitales por el asma.
Después de identificar el problema van a la segunda fase,
y dicen, vamos a descubrir la causa.
El análisis de la causa en la salud
es, usualmente, veamos tus genes,
veamos cómo te comportas.
A lo mejor no estás comiendo saludablemente.
"Come más saludablemente".
Es una visión muy simplista
al análisis de las causas.
Resulta que no funciona
cuando solo nos limitamos a esa visión.
Las causas que un nadador de "aguas arribas"
nos sugiere es, veamos las condiciones
de vivienda y trabajo en tu vida.
Quizá para los niños con asma
es lo que pasa en sus casas,
o quizá viven cerca de una autopista con bastante contaminación
que ocasiona el asma.
Quizá tenemos que mover recursos para resolver esto,
porque ese tercer elemento, esa tercera parte del proceso,
es la siguiente parte crítica que los "nadadores" hacen:
mover los recursos para crear una solución dentro del sistema clínico
y trayendo gente de la salud pública,
de otros sectores, abogados,
quien sea que quiera participar,
y crear soluciones que funcionen,
y llegar a esos pacientes que tienen problemas clínicos
y resolver juntos las causas,
al ponerlos en contacto con los recursos que necesitan.
Hay muchas historias
de "nadadores de aguas arribas" que hacen cosas importantes.
El problema es que no hay suficientes.
Según estimados necesitamos un "nadador"
por cada 20 a 30 médicos en el sistema de salud.
En EE. UU. por ejemplo,
eso sería unos 25 000 "nadadores"
para el 2020.
Pero solo tenemos unos cuantos miles de "nadadores" allá afuera,
y por eso hace unos años, con unos colegas,
dijimos, necesitamos capacitar
y hacer más "nadadores de aguas arriba".
Decidimos comenzar una organización
llamada Health Begins (La Salud Comienza)
y lo que simplemente hacemos es entrenar más de estos "nadadores".
Y hay muchas medidas para nuestro éxito,
pero lo que más nos interesa es darle confianza a los médicos
de poder hacer algo con respecto al "no preguntes, no digas".
Tratamos de asegurarnos de que los médicos
y el sistema donde trabajan
tengan la habilidad y la confianza
de que pueden resolver los problemas
de vivienda y trabajo en nuestras vidas.
Hemos visto triplicar nuestra confianza
en nuestro trabajo.
Es notable,
pero la parte más importante de trabajar
con estos "nadadores" es juntarlos.
Lo más notable es que todos los días, todas las semanas,
escucho historias similares a las de Verónica.
Hay muchas historias como las de Verónica
y muchos como ella,
gente que viene al sistema de salud
y puede ver lo que se siente
ser parte de algo que funciona,
un sistema de salud en el que dejas de entrar y salir
porque realmente mejora tu salud,
escucha quién eres, se enfoca en los contextos de tu vida,
ya sea que seas pobre o rico, o de clase media.
Estas historias son importantes porque no solo nos dicen que estamos
muy cerca del sistema de salud que queremos,
sino que hay algo que todos podemos hacer para lograrlo.
Los médicos y las enfermeras pueden ser mejores
cuando preguntan sobre las vidas de sus pacientes,
no solo porque es buena rutina, sino porque es un mejor cuidado.
Los sistemas de salud y los contribuyentes
pueden comenzar a ir a agencias y departamentos públicos de salud
y decir, analicemos juntos estos datos.
Veamos si descubrimos patrones en los datos
sobre la vida de los pacientes,
y veamos si descubrimos las causas,
y del mismo modo, veamos si podemos canalizar los recursos
para resolverlos.
Las escuelas de medicina, de enfermería,
todo tipo de programas de educación del sector salud,
pueden ayudar a entrenar la próxima generación de "nadadores".
También podemos asegurarnos de que estas escuelas
certifiquen a especialistas en este método,
que serían los trabajadores de la salud comunitarios.
Necesitamos más de estos en el sistema de salud
si queremos que sea efectiva la transición
de un sistema de cuidado de enfermedades a uno de cuidado de la salud.
Finalmente, y quizá los más importante es
¿qué hacemos?, ¿qué hacemos como pacientes?
Podemos comenzar yendo a nuestros médicos, enfermeros, clínicas,
y preguntar, "¿Hay algo en donde vivo
o donde trabajo a lo que debería prestarle atención?
¿Hay acaso obstáculos para la salud que desconozco,
y más importante, si hay obstáculos
que descubro, si vengo a Ud.
y les digo creo que hay un problema
en mi apartamento o sitio de trabajo
o, no tengo acceso a transporte,
o, el parque está muy lejos,
y lo siento doctor, pero no puedo seguir su consejo de ir a correr,
si esos problemas existen,
doctor, está Ud. dispuesto a escucharme?
Y ¿qué podemos hacer juntos
para mejorar mi salud por donde comienza?"
Si todos podemos hacer este trabajo,
médicos y sistemas de salud,
contribuyentes y todos juntos,
nos daremos cuenta de algo sobre la salud.
La salud no solo es una responsabilidad personal o un fenómeno.
La salud es un bien común.
Viene de nuestra inversión personal de saber que nuestras vidas importan,
que el contexto donde vivimos y trabajamos,
comemos y dormimos importa,
y que lo que hacemos para nosotros,
también debemos hacerlo para aquéllos
cuyas condiciones de vivienda y trabajo
pueden ser difíciles e incluso muy duras.
Todos podemos invertir en asegurarnos que mejoraremos
la cantidad de recursos que dedicamos a las causas,
pero a la vez, trabajar juntos al mismo tiempo
para demostrar que podemos mover el sistema de salud
hacia las causas.
Podemos mejorar la salud por donde comienza.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)